bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver sur public sénat au sommaire
de votre après midi dans un instant
direction l'hémicycle pour les
explications de vote sur le projet de
loi croissance activité et égalité des
chances d'économique le projet de loi
macro à 17 heures dans un autre temps
fort de l'actualité au sénat l'audition
conjointe de deux ministres bernard
cazeneuve et jean yves le drian sur le
projet de loi sur le renseignement et à
19h vous avez rendez vous avec votre
journal 24 heures sénat présenté par
delphine girard
mais d'abord je vous le disais à
l'instant le vote du projet de loi
macron le texte vient d'être adopté par
le sénat à 185 voix pour et 44 contre un
texte très différent de la version du
gouvernement et de celle de l'assemblée
nationale les sénateurs à majorité de
droite et du centre ont clairement
imprimé leur marque sur ce texte
on peut citer pêle-mêle
l'assouplissement du conte pénibilité
l'aménagement des seuils sociaux ou
encore le contournement des 35 heures
des mesures qui ne sont pas du tout du
goût du ministre de l'économie emmanuel
macron et qui n'ont pas satisfait non
plus l'opposition de gauche au sénat on
découvre tout de suite dans l'hémicycle
les explications de vote des différents
groupes ministre mes chers collègues
avant de passer au vote
je vais donner la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont été inscrits pour
expliquer leur vote
janicot c'est là que la conférence des
présidents a fixé à raison d'un orateur
par groupe à 7 minutes le temps attribué
à chaque groupe politique
les sénateurs de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe disposant de trois
minutes
je vous inviterai ensuite mes chers
collègues à vous rendre dans la salle
des conférences pour voter je suspendrai
la science pendant la durée du scrutin
prévu autour d'une demi heure je
proclamerai enfin le résultat à l'issue
du dépouillement à 15h 45 puis je
donnerai la parole monsieur le ministre
au gouvernement pour
commencez les explications de vote
la parole est à monsieur bruno
retailleau de pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues vous permettrait sans
doute pour commencer de saluer ceux qui
ont fait un énorme travail à part vous
monsieur le ministre
cent trente cinq heures aux bans et
c'est très long mais je voudrais tout
particulièrement salué notre collègue
vincent capo-canellas le président de la
commission spéciale
ils méritent ils méritent absolument vos
applaudissements et celle et celui qui
les méritent aussi ce sont les trois
rapporteurs catherine de roche
dominique estrosi sassone et et françois
piles et pour donner bord donner une
juste mesure de leur travail
sachez qu'à l'assemblée ils étaient neuf
rapporteur le rapport c'est un pur 3
vous voyez la capacité de travail des
sénateurs mes chers amis bien c'est un
c'est un gros travail qu'ils ont fait
c'est un gros travail parce que votre
texte monsieur ministre était copieux il
était lourd et en plus ils étaient
diverses son caractère éclectique n'a
échappé à personne
c'est un gros travail mais je trouve que
c'est un beau travail c'est un beau
travail parce que c'est un travail utile
utile pour les français
utile pour la france nous avons eu ici
il ya quelques semaines un texte qui
était arrivé qui plus est à fadi de
l'assemblée nationale mais qui était un
texte finalement assez emblématique de
la méthode du gouvernement
la méthode des petits pas des tout
petits pas avoir des petits pas de côté
voire des petits pas en arrière et nous
avons souhaité lui donner du souffle
nous avons souhaité lui donner un élan
réformateur
à un moment donné où la france traverse
une situation économique très très
difficile et nous avons voulu le faire
dans une approche constructive en
écartant les postures politiciennes les
postures idéologiques en écartant en
écartant aussi cette tentation de
s'arrimer à un certain nombre de
marqueurs
notre seule ligne notre seul horizon
c'est de l'intérêt supérieur du pays mes
chers collègues l'intérêt supérieur du
pays pour réformer la france
et vous non plus vous n'avez pas le
monopole mais nous avons travaillé avec
nos convictions et personne ne peut nous
rapprocher d'avoir nos convictions mais
nous avons essayé de trouver sur chacun
des points du texte des points
d'équilibré et nous avons fait nous
avons voté ce que nous avons dit que
nous voterions ce que nous ferions en
écartant les mesures qui nous
paraissaient contre-productive
par exemple la réforme par ordonnance de
l'inspection du travail sans doute un
gage donné aux frondeurs par exemple
donner du pouvoir donner plus de
pouvoirs à l'autorité de la concurrence
pour qu'elle se soucie de l'aménagement
du territoire en matière de professions
réglementées
qui ici peut penser que demain c'est en
remettant notre pouvoir à l'autorité de
la concurrence que nous n'aurons pas des
déserts juridique
après avoir eu des déserts médicaux mes
chers collègues nous avons trouvé grâce
à françois filer un point d'équilibré
qui n'est pas le statu quo où on a
avancé de même pour les tribunaux de
commerce
est-ce qu'il faut inventer de nouveaux
seuils bien seuil de 150 personnes
salariés et donc je pense que là encore
mme veron trouvait injuste point
d'équilibré
et puis nous avons conforté c'est vrai
tout ce qui allait dans le bon sens
parce que pourquoi ne pas le reconnaître
dans ce texte il y avait des mesures qui
allaient dans le bon sens je pense à la
libéralisation des transports part car
je pense aussi au financement
interentreprises je pense en même temps
quelques mesures de simplification
l'idée d'avoir pour chaque entreprise
une carte d'identité numérique qui
valent pour tout les les administrations
c'est positif et même monsieur le
ministre nos volontés se sont à quelques
reprises croisés sur la réduction de la
fracture numérique
évidemment nous sommes ici des obsédés
de cette réduction de la fracture parce
que nous savons trop ce que pèse le
manque de réseaux téléphonies mobiles ou
autres dans nos territoires
de même lorsque vous nous avez proposé
le vote de l'amendement sur le sur
amortissements nous l'avons voté
tout simplement parce que il ya six mois
en loi de finances
ensuite en loi de finances rectificative
nous avions nous-mêmes proposer des
mécanismes pour faire en sorte que l'on
puisse faciliter l'amortissement et
l'investissement des entreprises il n'y
a pas de reprise durable sans
investissement vous le savez bien
mais au-delà de ce que nous avons pu
conforter nous avons voulu muscler le
texte et nous avons lu le musclé pour
faire de ce texte un accélérateur de
croissance
en apportant ce qui manque le plus à
l'économie française de la souplesse et
de la simplification la souplesse nous
l'avons apporter non seulement sur les
accords défensif qui permet de sortir
des 35 heures mais sur les accords aussi
offensif
évidemment nous l'avons apporter cette
souplesse aussi en matière de droit du
travail de contrat de travail d'un
contrat de mission en matière de
plafonnement des indemnités de
licenciement il y un schisme chef
collègues qui vous a peut être échappé
savez vous quel est le délai moyen pour
que l'emploi en france adapte à
l'activité réelle de l'économie 24
trimestre six années en albanie les deux
cinq trimestres en italie il est de 2
trimestres
en grande bretagne il est de 2
trimestres vous avez là l'écart abyssal
qui sépare notre pays des autres pays et
vous avez en même temps la mesure des
réformes que nous devons faire donc nous
avons apporté de la souplesse et nous
avons voulu apporter avec le président
des commissions spéciales notre
rapporteur des mesures de simplification
simplification du conte pénibilité
simplification en même temps des seuils
sociaux de 10 à 20 en doublant de 50 à
c'est ce qui aujourd'hui entrave les
embauches dans nos pays d'enhaut était
évidemment de même que nous avons
souhaité là encore modifier le
dispositif de la loi monkey est en train
de bloquer la transmission d'entreprise
en france donc nous avons essayé d'être
constructif et je pense que c'est un
texte désormais qui va être soumis au
vote qui est un texte vraiment
réformateur désormais monsieur le
ministre vous avez un choix n'est pas
facile
vous avez le choix entre l'audace et la
prudence
l'audace si vous choisissez ce chemin
vous trouverez des hommes et des femmes
sénatrices et sénateurs de bonne volonté
au moment de la commission mixte
paritaire qui vous tendrons la main pour
faire en sorte que ces réformes puissent
aboutir
évidemment il ya un autre choix beaucoup
plus politicien un choix de calcul le
choix de la prudence
celui d'écouter les frondeurs celui de
se préparer celui de se préparer au
congrès de poitiers mes chers collègues
évidemment évident à bord mais je vais
vous dire il va falloir qu un seul
conseil
quitte à utiliser de 49,3 autant
l'utiliser pour quelque chose et je
terminerai je conclus laissez-moi
conclure laissez-moi kogure si vous
voulez abrégé mon intervention
laissez-moi conclure et pour conclure je
citerai je citerai bruno le roux je
citerai bruno le roux qui est évidemment
un excellent collègue puisqu'il préside
un grand groupe à l'assemblée nationale
qui a fait ce tweet absolument génial il
ya quelques jours en disant que quand on
a le courage de réformer ça peut payer
ça paye en allemagne avec mme merkel
et ça payé en grande bretagne avec
monsieur cameron
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir non
pas la posture mais la hauteur de vue
qui exige aujourd'hui la transformation
de l'économie française merci à vous il
la parole est maintenant président
françois zocchetto
monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'aimerais à mon tour débuté cette
explication de vote en remerciant
l'ensemble des collègues qui ont
participé aux débats et en particulier
la commission spéciale à travers son
président et ses rapporteurs qui sans
relâche ont tenu les positions de la
commission et du sénat pendant ces longs
débats et je crois sincèrement que notre
assemblée peut être fier du travail
accompli et du texte obtenus
le débat était nourri c'est un texte
sensiblement améliorées et complétées
qui est maintenant mis aux voix
et accessoirement mais pour nous ça ne
l'est pas ça démontre la vigueur du
bicamérisme et l'utilité du sénat avant
de parler du fond du texte je voudrais
dire quelques mots sur la sur la forme
car ce projet de loi comme
malheureusement d'autres avant lui tels
que le projet de loi allure est un texte
beaucoup trop long monsieur le ministre
et finalement ce texte s'éloigne de ses
objectifs initiaux par la dilution de
ces mesures principales au milieu de
dizaines d'articles supplémentaires et
il ya eu trop de thématiques diverses
aborder la loi gagnerait en lisibilité
et en efficacité si les textes étaient
plus courts
ça permettrait aussi des navettes plus
simple entre les deux chambres
car nous avons ici un bel exemple de
l'enrichissement mutuel du débat à
travers ce dialogue entre les deux
chambres
je comprends pas très bien les raisons
pour lesquelles le président de la
république françois hollande critiquer
le 19 avril dernier je cite la lenteur
des débats parlementaires
personne n'a jamais démontré que la
précipitation était l'allié du
législateur aussi cinq mois de débats
pour des mesures qui vont toucher à la
ville à la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens et aux conditions d'exercice
de nombreuses professions ne me semble
pas du tout être déraisonnable
disons le nettement si le gouvernement
était plus clair dans ses axes de
réformes
nous n'aurions pas à examiner des lois
si longue et si complexe
le sénat est en train de réformer ses
méthodes de travail
il fait bien mais je me permets de dire
que l'exécutif peut aussi en faire de
même car lorsqu'il y a des
longueur qui sont regrettés par le
président de la république est bien le
gouvernement on est probablement le
premier responsable j'en viens
maintenant au fond de ce projet de loi
nous partagions vous le savez bien
monsieur le ministre
le constat que vous avez dressé de
l'économie française
la france souffre selon vous de trois
mots la défiance la complexité le
corporatisme
ces trois sources sont bien connus il
est grand temps de s'y attaquer en effet
car la confiance des français s'est
largement détériorée nous sommes dans un
désagréable climat de défiance à l'égard
de nos institutions de ce qu'on appelle
la classe politique mais plus
généralement aussi de notre modèle
social et économique
si la confiance est si difficile à
retrouver
c'est parce que notre pays fonctionne au
ralenti depuis plusieurs années en effet
le retour la compétitivité tant espérée
se fait encore et toujours attendre et
le gouvernement peine à trouver des
réponses à une crise qui n'a que trop
duré et selon nous le gouvernement n'a
jamais su prendre ces derniers mois de
véritables mesures d'envergure ambitieux
et visionnaire
en effet seuls cela souvent été dit ici
à ces tribunes
seules des réformes structurelles
permettront à la france de se relever et
de retrouver son attractivité
or monsieur le ministre je n'ai vu dans
ce texte aucune réforme systémique de
notre fiscalité assourdissantes
je n'ai pas vu non plus de modernisation
de la fonction publique pour libérer des
emplois nous n'avons pas vu non plus de
réforme des retraites ou d'allégements
substantielle du droit du travail
ce ne sont pas les notaires ce ne sont
pas les huissiers les avocats ou encore
les commissaires priseurs qui étouffent
notre économie ce sont les 57 points de
pib consacrée à la dépense publique au
détriment de l'initiative privée et
qu'il verrouille tout esprit de réforme
et d'entreprises dans notre pays
alors face à ses doutes le sénat à
travailler propose aujourd'hui un texte
très différent plus riche plus ambitieux
pour notre pays qui permettra de
répondre d'ailleurs aux trois grands
axes du projet de loi que vous aviez
annoncé dans votre exposé préalable
alors bien sûr je ne peux pas citer
toutes les avancées réalisées au cours
des dernières semaines
je rappellerai les plus significatives
en termes de mobilité l'ouverture à la
concurrence des ter
dès le 1er janvier 2010 9,7 plusieurs
s'articule parfaitement avec la
clarification des compétences
recherchées par tous nous avons aussi
confirmé le doublement du montant de
plafond de la réduction isf pme
s'agissant de la réforme des professions
juridiques et judiciaires réglementée je
pense que l' approche a été tout à fait
raisonnable et est positive nous avons
réaffirmé la spécificité de la
prestation juridique et nous avons créé
un code de l'accès au droit et de
l'exercice du droit en matière de droit
du travail
soulignons les simplifications bienvenue
du comte de pénibilité avec la
suppression de la fiche individuelle et
la limite du nombre de facteurs mesurer
pour évaluer la pénibilité
nous avons aussi revu la le cadre des
accords aujourd'hui possible en
entreprise sur les 35 heures et je crois
monsieur le ministre que vous partagez
notre point de vue donc nous allons
passer d'accord défensif à des accords
offensif en donnant la souplesse
nécessaire aux entreprises dans le même
domaine le lissage des effets de
franchissement des seuils sociaux était
attendue depuis longtemps
enfin concernant le travail dominical
pour le droit du travail
je crois que nous avons su préserver
l'équilibré entre les zones touristiques
et commerciales d'une part et les zones
moins concernés et puis par ailleurs l'
équilibre entre le petit commerce et les
grandes surfaces
enfin et non des moindres le sénat a
adopté en début de semaine l'amendement
du gouvernement permettant de soutenir à
hauteur de deux milliards et demi
d'euros
les entreprises qui réaliseront des
investissements entre avril et 2015 et
avril 2016 j'hésite pour ne pas vous
compliquer la tâche monsieur le ministre
mais j'hésite à vous dire à quel point
c'est une satisfaction pour nous donc
nous ne parlerons pas de victoire mais
nous parlerons de grandes satisfactions
en tout cas pour notre groupe mais je
crois aussi pour l'ensemble de la
majorité sénatoriale puisque cet
amendement s'inscrit dans la filiation
de celui que nous avions déposé
proposées pendant le débat budgétaire de
l'automne dernier mais c'est surtout une
bonne nouvelle que cet amendement et
j'insiste parce que nous voulons
vraiment que ces dispositions soient
maintenus c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les entreprises françaises
en dépit malheureusement du temps perdu
et des mois qui ont été perdus puisque
ce cette dissolution aurait pu être
votée depuis longtemps
en conclusion nous étions partis en août
dernier il faut dire d'une approche
assez idéologique que vous aviez essayé
de traduire dans un texte présentable
qui faisaient néanmoins de plusieurs
professions les comptables et les boucs
émissaires des échecs de la politique
économique du gouvernement
nous avons vu c'est vrai arriver à un
texte plus mesurée mais largement
incomplet et surtout très confus
maintenant je crois pouvoir dire que
nous avons cet après-midi un texte
complètement remaniée bien sûr mais ce
qui surtout répond aux attentes de nos
concitoyens des professionnels des
entreprises et donc de la majorité
sénatoriale et c'est donc tout
naturellement que le groupe u10 us et
votera en faveur de ce projet de loi
tout en encourageant votre gouvernement
monsieur le ministre à préserver
au delà de notre séance les acquis du
débat sénatorial
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président
la parole est à peu près collègue nicole
bricq pour le groupe socialiste
chers collègues c'est le ministre
mesdames et monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président c'est pas de ma
faute si le prix migros ne marche pas
mais mes chers collègues je vous salue
et un texte d'une telle ampleur en porte
forcément sa propre marque dramaturgie
nous avons eu des temps forts
nous avons eu des temps plein du
surplace aussi et puis de brusques
amélioration et puis il faut bien le
dire des mouvements d'une heure aussi
c'est long le président ok tall a dit
mais si c'était long c'est parce que il
fallait aller vite et surtout et surtout
que rien n'avait été fait auparavant
les gouvernements successifs étaient
restés les bras croisés
et hier finalement nous étions heureux
d'en avoir fini et nous avons nous nous
sommes remercier congratuler mais
aujourd'hui non mais surtout nous étions
heureux de l'avoir fait dans le respect
des uns des autres
c'est important de le dire mais aussi
nous savions qu aujourd'hui nous
passerions à la partie politique au
choix qui nous est demandé et tous nous
avons salué l'engagement total du
ministre à l'unanimité cela a été
reconnu sa volonté de convaincre de
répondre point par point aux arguments
contraires d'où qu'ils viennent d'y
revenir sans arrogance avec la pédagogie
nécessaire
la majorité de la commission spéciale
son président ses rapporteurs dont il
faut saluer la constance la présence
continue il n'avait pas beaucoup bouger
de votre banc il faut bien le dire cette
majorité avait arrêté sa stratégie avec
la majorité sénatoriale pas de
confrontation systématique des
réécritures mais nous avons bien vu que
quelquefois les réécritures abouti c'est
finalement vallée suppression en tout
cas de l'esprit général du texte alors
il nous revenait à nous groupe
socialiste de tenir la ligne de soutien
à notre gouvernement
mais chaque fois qu'il s'est agi de
défendre et de maintenir des dispositifs
de négociation sociale et de dialogue
social contre des décisions unilatérales
des employeurs comme ça a été le cas
malheureux pour le travail du dimanche
nous nous y sommes opposés au principe
auquel nous ne dérogeons pas en la
matière pas d'accord pas d'ouverture
chaque fois que nous avons eues à
défendre notre conception de
l'entreprise et il y a eu plusieurs
débats quasiment philosophique mais très
politique
notre vision de l'entreprise je veux
répéter ici et elle est présente dans le
texte
ce n'est pas qu'une société une
entreprise une société de droit c'est
aussi et surtout une communauté
d'intérêts où les salariés doivent être
traités comme des parties prenantes
ce fut notamment le cas lorsqu'il s'est
agi du droit d'information des salariés
et je veux me dit vous dire monsieur le
président retailleau que nous n'avons
pas aimé mais vraiment pas aimé la
manière dont vous avez qualifié ce droit
d'information des salariés
j'ai cru au départ que c'était une
erreur de langage comme ça peut arriver
mais relisant les débats j'ai bien vu
que vous aviez utiliser le qualificatif
de toxiques pour dire ce que vous
pensiez de ce dispositif
et ça je considère c'est une mauvaise
action c'est une mauvaise parole
alors il eu des temps forts productif
je veux en retenir trois la matinée
consacrée à la couverture des zones
blanches et au déploiement de la fibre
qui a abouti à une position du
gouvernement adopté à l'unanimité et
monsieur le ministre vous avez tout de
suite convoquer les opérateurs pour
qu'ils s'engagent aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales et je crois
que c'est un honneur pour nous de
l'avoir votée ici au sénat et c'est le
sénat qui aura voté le mécanisme de sur
investissement pour les entreprises j'y
vois une marque de reconnaissance à
l'endroit de l'institution que nous
représentons de la part du gouvernement
et je l'en remercie bon travail
également que celui qui a conduit à un
accord sur le crédit interentreprises
il libère les entreprises des banques
toujours frileuses à les financer
mais il y aussi des temples à nous nous
avons fait du surplace l'impossibilité
de s'entendre sur la spécialisation de
certains tribunaux de commerce alors à
la vérité à la défense de la majorité et
notamment de la commission spéciale nous
avions quand même passé la merde matinée
à écouter le rapporteur convaincre sa
majorité qui était très rebelle a
évidemment ne pas voter la suppression
pour respecter votre stratégie est
évidemment après on peut comprendre que
vous ne vouliez plus rien céder à partir
du moment où vous aviez convaincu votre
majorité de retirer son nom son
amendement mais la commission spéciale a
eu également du mal à contenir cette
majorité et elle a pu quand même
entendre et prêter la main à quelques
débordements
j'en ai compté 10 mais qui ne sont pas
majeurs 10 je les ai comptées les
débordements ou finalement vous avez
cédé sur votre stratégie et malgré les
objurgations du président capo-canellas
il faut aussi le dit
vous n'avez pu empêcher que votre
majorité sénatoriale en rajoute dans les
exonérations fiscales non justifiées les
exonérations sociales et j'ai fait un
contre rapide j'ai fait un contre rapide
c'est quand même étonnant de la part de
ceux qui nous réclame plus de 100
milliards d'économies au dehors de cet
hémicycle d'en avoir rajouté une couche
dans la dépense à hauteur de près de 300
millions d'euros
enfin la majorité sénatoriale a voulu
déposer dans ce texte quelques marqueurs
politiciens essaient de bon coeur que la
commission spéciale finalement a suivi
sa majorité
dès lors qu'il s'est agi du social et du
travail on retiendra encore entre autres
encore une fois les agressions sur le
conte pénibilité et les seuils sociaux
décidément c'est faire peu de cas des
partenaires sociaux le renversement des
accords de maintien dans l'emploi
défensif en les transformant en accord
de maintien dans l'emploi offensif alors
même que vous le saviez très bien le
gouvernement très prochainement va
s'entretenir avec les partenaires
sociaux et la décision qui va être prise
sera traduite dans la navette
parlementaire
c'est une mauvaise manière faite au
gouvernement et c'est un mauvais coup
porté au dialogue social
si nous avons pu aboutir la réforme
terrible épreuve au mal nous n'avons pu
faire évoluer significativement les
professions du droit
car la majorité sénatoriale a été là
franchement conservatrice alors monsieur
le président à l'heure des comptes et du
choix
le groupe socialiste a considéré que le
texte pouvait assurer sa bonne fin dans
la navette parlementaire au service de
l'économie de la croissance et de
l'emploi pour la france et les français
certes il y à des mesures visant à
droitiser le texte mais elles n'ont reçu
aucun aval du gouvernement que nous
soutenons et fort heureusement elle ne
survivront pas à la nama
en conséquence la réforme l'emportera
sur la régression édition du 20 minutes
le motive notre abstention finale merci
la parole est à monsieur jean desessard
pour le groupe écologiste
la parole aux chers collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mesdames messieurs reporter le président
de la commission spéciale chers
collègues avec quinze jours de débat le
sénat a terminé l'examen de l'un des
plus longs textes que notre assemblée a
eu à étudier sur la forme j'ai eu
l'occasion hier de souligner le bon
climat des débats grâce à l'ecoute
constructive je voulais dit monsieur le
ministre
deux ministres également des rapporteurs
et du président de la commission
spéciale sur le fond dans sa philosophie
générale le projet de loi nous propose
de déverrouiller un certain nombre de
secteurs dans l'objectif affiché de
créer de l'activité de la croissance
ouverture de ligne privée d'autocars
liberté d'installation et regroupant des
professions réglementées simplification
du droit de l'environnement
ouverture facilité des commerces
dimanche et la nuit
telles sont certaines des propositions
qui nous sont faites
tout d'abord monsieur le ministre nous
avons une réserve sur le potentiel de
croissance que vous pensez obtenir avec
ces mesures de dérégulation ensuite dans
votre volonté de produire toujours plus
toujours plus vous qualifiez d'obstacles
des règles qui veulent préserver notre
patrimoine notre environnement
vous qualifiez d'obstacles dégâts règles
qui garantissent le droit des salariés
disposez de temps libre
vous qualifiez d'obstacles des règles
qui garantissent l'éthique des
professions réglementées
cependant afin de limiter l'impact
négatif de certaines mesures
vous avez prévu des contreparties ces
contreparties permettent à votre effort
d'atteindre un point d'équilibré que
l'on peut qualifier de social libéral
mais que se passera-t-il si une nouvelle
majorité est aux commandes
et c'est un nouveau ministre de
l'économie occupe votre poste le projet
de loi ouvre des brèches qui peuvent
être exploitées d'un logique tout autre
que celle de l'actuel gouvernement
le projet social libéral peut très
facilement devenir uniquement libéral et
c'est précisément ce qui s'est dores et
déjà produit lors d'examens du texte au
sénat la majorité de droite où la
majorité sénatoriale ne soyez pas vexer
à profiter de votre projet de loi
monsieur le ministre pour y apposer sa
marque et rompre l'équilibré que vous
proposez sur le travail dominical et
nocturnes
les entreprises auront la possibilité de
déroger très largement contrepartie en
s'affranchissant du dialogue social cela
a été dit puisque le transport par
autocar et libéraliser la droite la
majorité sénatoriale en a également
profité pour adopter un amendement
visant l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire régional
et puisque l'on traite largement du
droit du travail pourquoi s'arrêter
pourquoi ne pas scorer trois jours de
carence en fonction publique
hospitalière et territoriale relever les
seuils sociaux et permettent de déroger
aux 35 r le risque d'une dérive libérale
n'est donc pas hypothétique
nous en avons eu la preuve avec le texte
qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui de
voter nous déplorons également
l'amendement cigéo adopté cet amendement
est adopté à 5 heures du matin juste
avant la suspension de séance de deux
semaines et puisqu'on n'était pas sûr de
pouvoir la voir ce jour là puisqu'on
devait terminer ce hacker il était
remonté serait donc nous sommes
effectivement fortement opposés à ceux
d'amendement du projet jje cigéo de
stockage des déchets radioactifs à bure
cependant pour être objectif il faut
acter le travail du sénat sur plusieurs
points comme le relèvement de la limite
kilométrique de déclaration des lignes
d'autocars
fr pour ne pas concurrencer line public
la suppression de l'article 29 qui
empêchait la démolition de bâtiment
subit un recours contentieux ou encore
la position équilibrée prouvé sur les
professions réglementées en redonnant la
main ministère de la justice sur les
installations et en encadrant des
remises malgré tout ces quelques
avancées ne change rien notre analyse
globale
nous refusons la logique de ce texte qui
pensent que la croissance en rendez vous
de la dérégulation et qu'il faut de la
dérégulation pour créer de la croissance
et nous sommes je l' ai déjà dit inquiet
qu'une autrement majorité s'engouffre
dans la brèche ouverte pour toujours
plus de des règles des régulations
toujours plus de dérégulation au nom
d'une hypothétique croissance
cette nouvelle majorité monsieur le
ministre n'aura pas les limites que vous
êtes imposé dans cette loi en conclusion
les écologistes voteront donc contre ce
projet de loi
merci collègues
mode la parole est maintenant à madame
la présidente eliane assassi pour le
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
vous avez la parole madame la présidente
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avant de
donner l'appréciation globale du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen sur le
fond de ce projet de loi je voudrais
m'arrêter quelques instants sur la forme
du débat parlementaire
nous avons dû examiner en trois semaines
de débats un véritable monstre juridique
ces sables mouvants législatifs ont gêné
la prédation l'appréhension des
parlementaires mais aussi des citoyens
comme nous l'avons indiqué lors de notre
motion d'irrecevabilité la loi doit être
intelligible compréhensible pour tous
votre texte les t-il monsieur le
ministre
hors de ces murs at il permis à un
véritable débat dans le pays sur les
choix de société que vous portez à
savoir le libéralisme cette question de
femmes n'est pas un détail
à l'heure où le sénat annonce vouloir se
réformer une question se pose une
démocratie parlementaire peut-elle
fonctionner en étant soumise à une telle
inflation législative ce texte je le
rappelle regroupe l équivalent est gelée
d'hier encore d'au moins 15 projets de
loi au regard de la masse de ces
dispositions est par ailleurs il
admissible d'imposer la procédure
accélérée 600 amendements au moins ont
été adopté au sénat
serait-il acceptable que l'assemblée
nationale ne reprennent pas ce texte
alors que rappelons le elle ne l'a pas
adopter en tant que tel puisque faute de
majorité de gauche pour vous soutenir
monsieur le ministre monsieur le premier
ministre a dû dégainer brutalement et
brusquement le 49-3 un accord on cmp qui
paraît invraisemblable est semblable
temps les amendements de la droite
sénatoriale pousse les feux du
libéralisme à leur paroxysme
ce serait une violence inadmissible fait
à la majorité de l'assemblée nationale
assez dizaine de sénateurs de gauche
socialistes en particulier qui avait
déjà refusé la dérive libérale du texte
initial monsieur le ministre c'est une
question grave je sais votre intention
d'aller vite dans ce débat car vous êtes
aussi inquiet des effets dévastateurs
que pourrait avoir dans l'opinion et
dans les locales et l'électorat de
gauche
la divulgation de multiples capitulation
devant le marché que comprend ce texte
votre texte monsieur le ministre nous
l'avons dit et répété tout au long de ce
débat une cohérence il à la cohérence
d'un libéralisme assumé d'un libéralisme
qui envahit tous les aspects de la vie
publique et privée d'un libéralisme que
vous assumez pleinement
alors que les élections du 6 mai 2012
ont justement voulu voulu y mettre un
terme et pour une bonne part
radicalement il sans compromis à la
dérive libérale des années de monsieur
nicolas sarkozy alors votre texte
monsieur macron c'est la dérouillée
dérégulation à tout va avec l'ouverture
massive des lignes de transport routier
de voyageurs au détriment de la sécurité
de l'écologie quitte à affaiblir l'un
des atouts majeurs de notre pays le
ferroviaire
la concurrence c'est votre maître mot
mettre en concurrence faire jouer la
concurrence
la compétition pourquoi ne pas dire le
combat les idéaux de fraternité
d'égalité de liberté celle de bien vivre
de s'épanouir
pas celle de vendre d'acheter
d'exploiter son ou noyées dans votre
océan normatif dérégulation concurrence
est aussi les points clés des
dispositifs de privatisation adoptée par
ce projet monsieur le ministre vous nous
refaites le coût des autoroutes avec les
aéroports la collectivité le peuple
investis pour des grandes
infrastructures très rentable voulait
céder au privé voulait céder aux
actionnaires comment ces de s'étonner
que dès à présent
l'ombre du qatar plane sur les aéroports
concernés lyon et nice
l'industrie de défense elle même est
soumise à la pression du privé dans un
partenariat surprenant avec un géant
l'historique de l'armement allemand au
risque de perdre le lien nécessaire
entre un moment et diplomaties
nationales
même le secteur du logement n'a pas
trouvé grâce à vos yeux
puisque vous privilégiez le logement
intermédiaire en remettant en cause
l'effort réel pour le logement social
initié par madame duflot discrètement
vous multipliez les dispositions en
faveur de l'actionnariat actionnariat
salarié dites vous mais nous l'avons
démontré avec le dispositif d actions
gratuites de l'article 34 ce sont les
cadres dirigeants qui seront les
principaux bénéficiaires de ces nouveaux
cadeaux jamais jamais votre texte
n'évoque de faire participer à l'effort
de croissance les banques et les
détenteurs de capitaux
enfin le volet social de votre texte est
en train de régressions majeures
extension du travail à 12 images par an
avec une généralisation perspective
remise en cause des prud'hommes et de
l'inspection du travail instauration
d'une procédure civile qui placera le
salarié devant les avocats tout puissant
du patronat ces quelques mots ne
permettent pas de reproduire
l'ampleur des transformations que vous
proposez pour conclure je vais m'arrêter
sur les conséquences des mesures
sénatoriale adoptée avec votre
assentiment la droite monsieur le
ministre nous a manifesté un soutien
constant durant ce débat vous
applaudissant à maintes reprises les
grands axes du projet que je viens
d'évoquer son approbation à l'exception
remarquer et sexuelle exception
remarquée des articles sur les
professions juridiques
elle va plus loin et trop souvent
monsieur ministre avec votre approbation
extension du travail du dimanche avec
l'exonération des contreparties pour les
entreprises de moins de onze salariés
l'ouverture des enseignes culturelles
car la culture le dimanche doit être
vendre et consommer dérogation aux 35
heures avec les uns les accords offensif
régression des droits limitation de la
formation des salariés en battant
brescia loi à mon augmentation des
seuils sociaux pour diminuer les droits
collectifs des salariés destruction du
conte pénibilité
et enfin mis en place avec votre accord
monsieur le ministre c'est dans le
journal officiel d'une commission pour
réécrire la demande du groupe à la
demande du groupe ump
un nouveau code du travail simplifié
monsieur gattaz a du bien dormir le soir
du vote de cet amendement
que dire aussi de la privatisation des
trains régionaux autorisé par la
majorité sénatoriale au protectionniste
est un formidable récit des réceptacles
pour toutes les régressions sociales il
ouvre la boîte de pandore en brisant les
digues construites en france durant des
décennies par les luttes des salariés du
peuple symbolisée par le programme des
jours heureux du cnr pour vous le droit
au travail est un handicap à l'expansion
du marché et vous avez raison
là où il a sombré en grande bretagne
aux usa les inégalités ont cru la
pauvreté s'est développée nous refusons
votre modèle de société que beaucoup à
droite de cet hémicycle pop nous savons
qu'à gauche
nous ne sommes pas seuls et nous agirons
pour rappeler que la gauche à d'autres
valeurs celle de l'humain de l'égalité
et du partage et qu'elle porte des
propositions alternatives comme nous
l'avons démontré tout au long des débats
le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen votera donc contre ce projet
aggravée si cela était encore possible
par la droite sénatoriale
merci ils aiment l'appeler zilok dernier
orateur que les gens que brooke et pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
social et européen
vous avez la parole mon cher mais si les
ministres mais sa collègue au terme de
ces trois semaines l'examen en séance
publique ce projet de loi no 30
assemblée a adopté en sciences pas moins
de 280 amendement s'ajoutant aux travaux
de la commission spéciale dont il salue
le travail
le président et le rapporteur et
conduisant à des modifications puisque
substantielle par rapport au texte
transmis par assemblée nationale accord
spécial comme en sciences
le groupe rdse a apporté sa contribution
un texte habib ambitieux trop
probablement pour l'avenir notre pays
tant par la diversité des sujets abordés
que par son impact sur l'état d'esprit
général mais aussi surtout ceux passant
pas des aspects des concret de la vie de
nos concitoyens
ce projet de loi restera une texte hors
normes ayant permis de battre les série
de records
à l'issue de ce travail d'un marathon
législatif temps les organismes ont été
mis à rude épreuve jusqu'au bout de la
nuit quelques fois nous estimons dans
l'ensemble que le texte sur lequel nous
allons nous prononcer aujourd'hui et
meilleurs ou moins mauvais que l'on sera
d'options dans les conditions que l'on
sait par assemblée nationale cependant
il ne donne pas non plus pleine et
entière satisfaction et nous maintenons
d'importantes créances sur bien des
points mais qui peut pleinement être
ratifié par un texte qui contient autant
d'articles et embrasse autant de sujets
de la même façon qui peut dire qu'il n'y
a pas de bonnes choses dans ce texte
dans sa version gouvernementale comme
dans ses versions assemblée nationale où
senna hélas si dans le maquereau ou tout
n'est pas bon tous les parents auraient
l'en but
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la question du travail dominical n'est
pas pour nous la pluie l'essentiel et la
majorité des membres d'autres groupes a
adopté les articles sans grande
difficulté je ne reviendrai donc pas en
détail cette réforme
bien qu'elle ait beaucoup retenu
l'attention des médias de même le sens
favorable aux dispositions relatives à
la gouvernance et aux opérations sur le
capital des sociétés à participation
publique
en revanche d'autres domaines on
constitue une priorité pour nous comme
logement la vie des entreprises
le droit au travail et bien sûr les
professions réglementées thème sur
lequel le président nezar s'est beaucoup
investi dans certains cas nous sommes
satisfaits d'avoir pu convaincre la
haute assemblée tandis que l'europe
nous déplorons que le texte n'ait pu
être sérieusement amendé dans la salle
de nos convictions et dans concession d
intérêt général
premièrement dans le domaine du logement
l'adoption d'un amendement permettra de
mettre en oeuvre dutil mesure
simplification de facilitation et de
reddition des délais notamment la
construction de logements sociaux
il encouragera également le
développement de l'habitat par site
participatif
quant à l'élargissement de la
composition de la commission nationale
de l'aménagement de l'urbanisme du
foncier à une représentation des
professionnels de l'aménagement et
insistera davantage d'efficacité et de
pluralisme dans ce secteur dans le cadre
experts comptables deux ont permis la
suppression par le sénat de la
possibilité d'instaurer une rénumération
au succès pour les activités exercées à
titre accessoire évite un cela les
dérives bien connu dans les pays anglo
saxons enfin dans le domaine de la
justice commerciale notre ténacité ya
impayés avait adopté la présence de
droit des présidents de tribunaux
commerce aux siennes de formation du
jugement des tribunaux spécialisés
cette présence permettra d'adopter
d'apporter une expertise et une
connaissance du terrain
nous préservons donc comme principe de
proximité dans la gestion des affaires
car monsieur le ministre il voit en
général votre copie n'est pas assez
marqué par vote en fait en bas du
terrain
des territoires et des réalités vécues
par les français c'était cette marque
que le rdse
et puis on va le sénat auront permis
d'inscrire dans ce texte
oui le sénat est utile ces trois
semaines le débat enfants une nouvelle
démonstration et monsieur le ministre
quelque chose me dit que vous y êtes
sensible pour ne pas dire un convaincu
cela étant dit bien des sujets
d'insatisfaction et de préoccupations de
marc demain pour nous tout ou partie des
membres d'un groupe d'abord concernant
le volet mobilité et libéralisation des
services de transport nous déplorons que
les enjeux spécifiques aux territoires
ruraux n'est pas davantage été pris en
compte
nous soutenons qui n'est pas de bonne
politique et remettent en cause la
pérennité du réseau ferroviaire
secondaires seuls garants de l'équilibré
entre les territoires au profit du
transport routier guen d'encourager
l'égalité des chances le texte risque
d'aggraver les inégalités territoriales
en favorisant ceux qui seront là
économique et territoriale ont déjà le
plus d'atouts sur la réforme de la
justice des prud homales à volonté de
réduire les deux jugements est certes
louable mais un risque en l'état
d'accueil variations du texte débouché
sur la justice au rabais
avant même de complexifier les
procédures plus que jamais si l'on veut
développer une culture de conciliation
il faut avoir le courage de mobiliser
les moyens pour former les conseillers
prud'homaux à celle ci de même nous
inquiétons de la mesure adoptée vise à
supprimer affiche individuelle du code
depuis débilité bien que le soyons pas
si favorable à un assouplissement ne
voulons pas que l'initiative
simplification se fasse au détriment des
salariés les plus vulnérables enfin la
réforme des professions réglementées
reste à me précieux à nos yeux la partie
la plus discutable des projets de loi
nous regrettons les mesures adoptées sur
la liberté d'installation des avocats
qui risque de renforcer le désir
juridique est entré une perte de matière
grise notamment dans les territoires
ruraux qui une nouvelle voie sont les
premières victimes
la postulation des jeunes avocats au
tribunal d'instance préserver cet
équilibre et nous regrettons 5000 en
côte
mais ça colle à sa collègue le sénat
aura vaincu sur le devoir de à terme
devenir suivi positif
puis largement nous restons opposés à la
vision pas trop technocratique et
parisienne et qui se dégage selon nous
des articles concernant les avocats les
notaires et huissiers et les
fournisseurs après l'heure c'est encore
trop déconnecté des réalités locales du
terek monsieur le ministre socialiste le
terrain venez encore des territoires les
français vous avez montré votre votre
intérêt pour la ruralité lors de laurie
séchage sur la couverture de téléphonie
mobile qui a duré série de matinée
désormais votre agenda est quelque peu
allégé aussi profité d'un homme pour
sortir de bercy venez venez dans le
monde
déguster au passage une bécasse aléas
lozère aller dans le cantal dans le gers
et même en corrèze et de préférence
prenez le train ou la route à moins que
vous ne préfériez l'autocar bien
évidemment notre salle des inconnus de
la responsabilité et de la mesure nous
amène à recruter de d'erreur de 20 les
améliorations nous saluons ainsi les
progrès réalisés à l'esat et
d'importants piller consent les avocats
au conseil
bien que des modifications apportées
n'aille pas suffisant guen
l'article adopté par le sénat est prêt à
fra bat celui en deux introduit à 100 b
dans les conditions rappelées pendant
que blizzard lors de salons
internationaux a conclu un conclusion
didier droit y compris sur le ministre
sa collègue notre groupe porte jugement
nuancé son projet de loi tel qu amendé
par la prod semblait nous constatons une
amélioration indéniable par rapport au
texte sorti de l'assemblée n'est
toutefois il nous est impossible de
soutenir pleinement aussi viennent un
scénario initial que dans sa version
issue des travaux du sénat c'est la
raison pour laquelle la majorité d'entre
nous fera le choix de l'abstention
un choix comme toujours au gardien ceux
exprimés librement et en responsabilité
dit mon cher collègue
il va donc être procédé dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 du
règlement au scrutin public sur
l'ensemble du projet doit pour la
croissance d'activité l'égalité des
chances d'économique il aura lieu en
salle des conférences
conformément aux dispositions du
chapitre 15 bis de l'instruction
générale du bureau une seule délégation
de vote est admise par sénateurs et les
trois secrétaires du sénat madame tasca
jean pierre leleux et jean desessard
supervisant les opérations de vote
voilà vous venez de suivre les
explications de vote sur le projet de
loi croissance activité et égalité des
chances d'économique que vous connaissez
aussi sous le nom de projet de loi macro
je vous le rappelle le texte a été
adopté par le sénat cet après midi à 191
voix pour 44 voix contre un texte très
différent de la version initiale du
gouvernement et de celle de l'assemblée
nationale le sénat à majorité de droite
et du centre a clairement imprimé sa
marque sur ce texte
députés et sénateurs vont désormais
devoir se mettre d'accord pour arriver
en commission mixte paritaire à une
version commune
une commission mixte paritaire qui a de
très fortes chances d'échouer
autre temps fort de cet après midi au
sénat l'audition conjointe de deux
ministres le ministre de l'intérieur et
le ministre de la défense bernard
cazeneuve et jean yves le drian par la
commission des lois et celle des
affaires étrangères au programme bien
évidemment le projet de loi sur le
renseignement un texte très attendu ici
au sénat qui a été adoptée je vous le
rappelle en première lecture la semaine
dernière par l'assemblée nationale le
projet de loi définit les missions des
services de renseignement et
l'autorisation de techniques
d'espionnage un texte très controversé
décrié par la société civile pour son
manque de contre-pouvoir et son
caractère intrusif
on découvre tout de suite en audition
les réponses des deux ministres